i'm actually the general manager of the
world's largest cannabis dispensary
uh do you mind if sona takes over the
interview now
[Laughter]
i feel like you're you're asking me
medical questions and i'm s and sona is
the surgeon general and so
i feel like sona needs to
well wait a minute when you say when you
say this is the biggest uh
marijuana or wheat store how big we
talking here uh we have just under 10
000 square feet of sale space
and 77 registers
wait wait you have 77 registers yeah
bigger bigger than most stores in
general but the biggest uh dispensary is
just because people are so high that
they can't find a register and you have
to have them every two square foot
actually you know what they're so high
that they go to multiple registers and
pay multiple times
that's why they have them
they just they pay 10 times over for one
bag of
gummies because they're like whoa
well i should pay wait there's another
register whoa okay ring me up
wow okay so
wait so you're like let me see if i got
this straight you're like the costco for
weed
yeah it's very big we have a huge open
display um everything is uh in nice
cases so if you're looking for flour you
go to the flower section check it out
there if you're looking for your gummies
you would go to the edible section and
you check those out
yeah it's like willy wonka's weed
factory in a lot of ways yeah that is so
cool basically right now sona is cookie
monster
and
and you're talking about how you have
the largest cookie manufacturer in the
world and she's she just wants to throw
it all into her mouth but like the
puppet it won't even go in it'll just
come up
[Laughter]
so wait a minute um
paint the picture let's say yeah okay
sona and i walk into this massive
massive costco of weed yeah and it
sounds pretty fancy
but
are there sales people walking around
yes so first so you walk into a grand
hallway actually so we have the grand
hallways the dispensary check in uh so
that's where you first meet our
reception crew you know a nice big
greeting there we have a full restaurant
um
i bet you too oh that's cool i bet
you're doing guess what the food doesn't
have to be that good
i'm sure it is i'm sure it is good but
it really doesn't have to be
just fine today's special is is four day
old reheated pizza
[Music]
your bean bag sir oh thank you
and i'll have the three day old pizza
uh
with a pint of ice cream yeah so walking
past uh so you walk past the restaurant
and uh so we have the sales floor that i
mentioned um and there's a digital line
instead of a physical one that you see
in most dispensaries that you're kind of
used to
but
then you'll meet one of our cannabis
consultants
they'll walk you through answer any of
your questions wait there are cannabis
consultants on the floor yeah
if i went to like a best buy
someone would say well this is okay i'll
take you over and show you the flat
screens absolutely but they get to try
every flat screen what yeah and your
flat screen and flat and wait there are
free samples well yeah in a way yeah so
we can't uh so well my blood tenders
yeah this the consultants get the free
product from the sales people like any
others like any other sales groups
yeah so they got to grease the wheels
that way are you hiring
and are you high
please answer the question in that order
mr gourley it's middle to work today
uh call him officer officer in the
middle of the work day
so i'm curious would
would sona
if we sent sona to you to work there for
a
day
do you think i mean she is an avid
consumer okay do you think she would be
uh
do you think she'd be
i mean do you want to interview her
right now and see if she's going to sort
with with with all respect and
congratulations of course we'd have to
wait until after the weaning right so
like after after you're done feeding the
the children that's true god matthew you
are so [ __ ] good you are so you are
so
you are the you are so so good i'd like
to see you
in giving senate testimony and everyone
would try and nail you and you'd be like
well i'm sorry senator but of course you
understand
and you would totally win you're the
smoothest character i've met in a while
uh
yes let's say let's say sona was not
breastfeeding her children yeah um and
she was at a stage where that was not a
consideration but good catch there
matthew if you wanted to come through
and do a day on the sales floor i would
welcome you with open arms absolutely
wow oh my god can i take some stuff home
with me too like you can i wouldn't let
you leave without it hey
yeah if you come work for me if you come
work for me you get to yeah you get to
smoke for free that's just